WASHINGTON D.C. WHEN PEOPLE DO
STRANGE THINGS LIKE THIS,
CREATURES OF THE SWAMP, THEY ARE
DOING IT FOR A REASON.
MARK PENN JOINS US NOW WITH
PRESS SECRETARY SEAN SPICER.
MARK I DIDN'T EXPECT YOU TO BE
ON THE PROGRAM.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE.
WE HAVE BEEN OPPOSING EACH OTHER
FOR MANY YEARS.
WE HAVE NEVER HAD THIS HAPPEN TO
AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT EVER.
IT'S NEVER BEEN THIS BAD.
WE GOT PFIZER LIES.
WE HAVE A DEEP STATE, SPIES IN A
CAMPAIGN.
THIS IS BAD FOR THE COUNTRY.
EXPLAIN WHAT YOU MEANT.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
I SPENT A YEAR FIGHTING KEN
STARR WHEN I THOUGHT THAT WAS
WRONG.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ON FOX NEWS WERE
GUNG HO IN THAT.
I SAW HOW DESTRUCTIVE IT WAS TO
THE PRESIDENCY, THE PEOPLE
AROUND HIM AND IT RESULTED IN
NOTHING.
I'M A SKEPTICAL PERSON.
AT FIRST IT SEEMED LIKE A GOOD
PROCESS.
IT MADE SENSE.
MORE AND MORE QUESTIONS CAME TO
THE FORE.
HOW DID THIS GET STARTED?
WHAT TECHNIQUES WERE USED?
WHAT WAS BEHIND THE WARRANT?
PEOPLE ARE RAIDING PEOPLE AND
SHAMING THEM AND THREATENING
RELATIVES.
THIS SEEM LIKE A CHARGE CHAMBER
SERIES OF EVENTS.
THIS IS OPENING AWP AFTER
THIS IS OPENING UWP AFTER
THIS IS OPENING UPP AFTER
THIS IS OPENING UP AAFTER
THIS IS OPENING UP AFTTER
THIS IS OPENING UP AFTERR
THIS IS OPENING UP AFTER A YEAR
AND TESTIMONY OF THE
INTELLIGENCE CHIEFS, THEY NEVER
SAID THEY WERE USING THIS KIND
OF INTELLIGENCE.
THEY WERE HIDING WHAT THEY WERE
DOING WHILE THEY WERE DOING IT
DEMOCRAT OR REPUBLICAN, MORE
PEOPLE HAVE TO COME TOGETHER AND
SAY ENOUGH.
WE CAN'T CRIMINALIZE POLITICS.
I MAY NOT AGREE WITH YOU OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP ON TONS OF
ISSUES, BUT I AGREE ON THIS, THE
WAY I HAVE SEEN THIS UNFOLD.
>> IF WE ARE GOING TO HAVE, AND
NO OFFENSE TO HILLARY, THE
CLINTONS YOU WORK WITH.
IF SHE PAYS FOR OP RESEARCH,
THAT'S PART OF POLITICS, BUT A
FOREIGN NATIONAL PUTTING
TOGETHER A DOSSIER AND RAW
INTELLIGENCE, MAYBE 50/50, AND
THAT BECOMES THE BULK OF
INFORMATION TO OBTAIN A WARRANT,
RENEWAL APPLICATIONS AND THEN WE
HAVE SPIES IN THE CAMPAIGN?
THAT'S NOT THE UNITED STATES TO
ME.
YOU EVEN MENTION THE DEEP STATE,
YOU USE THE TERM, THAT TO ME,
WE'LL LOSE THE COUNTRY IF THE
TOOLS OF INTELLIGENCE ARE TURNED
ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE THIS WAY.
>> I SAY THE DEEP STATE APPEARS
TO BE IN A STATE OF DESPERATION.
THEY KNOW THE IG REPORT IS
COMING DOWN, NIEWN EASY
COMING DOWN, NUNWN EASY
COMING DOWN, NUNEZ EASY
COMING DOWN, NUNEZ AASY
COMING DOWN, NUNEZ ANDY
GOTTEN TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
YOU SEE HOW THEY ARE CHANGING
THEIR STORIES DAY-TO-DAY, T.V.
TALKING HEADS, INCREDIBLE TO
THINK THE HEAD OF OUR NATIONAL
INTELLIGENCE SISTER AND BROTHER.
I
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GI
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GG
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GT
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GO
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GC
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GM
ESTABLISHMENT.I THINK THIS IS GE
DOWN.
I PRESUME COMEY IS NOT COMING
OUT OF THE BOX AS A WITNESS.
WE ARE ALL WRONG, IT WILL CHANGE
MY MIND, BUT IT'S HARD TO SEE IT
NOT COMING DOWN THAT WAY.
>> I'M CALLING THIS THE BIGGEST
ABUSE OF POWER CORRUPTION
SCANDAL IN HISTORY.
WATER GATE A BREAK IN, PRESIDENT
RESIGNING, COVER UP ENSUED.
THIS IS A SOPHISTICATED
OPERATION SPYING ON ANY CAMPAIGN
AND LYING TO GET A FYZA WARRANT.
YOU HAVE TO LIE BEFORE A JUDGE
TIME AFTER TIME AND NOT TELLING
THEM THIS IS OFF RESEARCH PAID
FOR BY THE OTHER PARTY.
>> AND THE OTHER THING IMPORTANT
TO NOTE, THE STORIES ABOUT COMEY
AND CLAPPER HAVE CONTINUED TO
EVOLVE AND CHANGE BETWEEN WHAT
THEY ORIGINALLY SAID HAPPENED
AND WHAT THEY SAY HAPPENED NOW.
AS MORE INFORMATION COMES OUT,
TRE NUNEZ AND OTHERS AS TO WHAT
HAPPENED, THE PRESIDENT IS
RIGHT, WE HAVE TO GET TO THE
BOTTOM OF IT, FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED, WHEN IT HAPPENED, WHO
ORDERED IT TO HAPPEN AND WHY IT
WAS DONE.
WE HAVE MORE AND MORE QUESTIONS
COME OUT THE MORE PEOPLE DIG IN.
YOU LOOK AT PEOPLE LIKE TRE
DOUDY AND OTHERS IN THE SENATE,
THE MORE QUESTIONS, THE MORE
THEY GET ATTACKED.
PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
FINDING OUT THE TRUTH, WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHO ORDERED IT.
>> MARK, WHERE ARE YOUR LIBERAL
FRIENDS?
ALAN DER SH WITS, I AGREE HIM ON
ISSUE IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
ISRAEL, OUR CLOSEST ALLY.
WHERE ARE THE CIVIL LIBERTARIANS
SUPPOSEDLY IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY BECAUSE THEIR VOICES HAVE
BEEN SILENT.
IS IT POLITICAL DIFFERENCES THAT
THEY ARE WILLING TO ACCEPT THIS
TYPE OF INTELLIGENCE ABUSE AND
ABUSE OF POWER AND SPYING ON
OTHER CANDIDATES.
>> ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE ACLU
THAT USED TO BE FOR THE FIRST
AMENDMENT NO MATTER WHAT HAVE
CHANGED POLICY BECAUSE YOU CAN
RAISE MORE MONEY BEING ON ONE
SIDE OR THE OTHER.
I'M DISAPPOINTED MORE ARE NOT
CONCERNED ABOUT WHAT IS GOING ON
WITH THE FBI.
THIS IS ABOUT ALL CAMPAIGNS.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THE DEEP STATE TO
OPERATE IN THIS MANNER.
WE HAVE TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
>> IF YOU WERE TAKING HEAT FOR
WRITING THE ARTICLE, WAIT UNTIL
YOUR OLD FRIENDS SEE YOU ON THIS
SHOW.
GOD HELP YOU.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU ARE